[Music]
recently the Monster Jam came to Los
Angeles at Dodger Stadium and it
featured some of the most famous monster
trucks
all right including one of the most
famous of all time gravedigger
and thank you sir they invited me to
check out the monster trucks I got this
call Conan do you want to come see the
monster trucks
I love monster trucks and I said I'd be
interested they said I might even be
able to drive one which sounded amazing
to me yeah so I was in I was like this
is really exciting so I got a camera
crew and we went out to Dodger Stadium
we saw the monster trucks here's what
happened when you think of America you
think of apple pie the right to bear
arms the music of Kenny Loggins and of
course the monster truck nothing says
America wins like a 15-foot tall vehicle
that gets over nine inches to the gallon
this is Dan right yes Dan and you are
Charlie yes sir and you guys drive these
monster trucks yeah what's the coolest
thing that you've crushed in one of
these babies
probably a Motorhome you crushed a
Motorhome did you give the people a
chance to get out first or yesterday
tell me the dimensions of one of these
trucks it's about 12 foot wide 12 foot
high weighs 10,000 pounds makes about
$1,500 power if I took this out on the
highway what's the highest speed that
this would do um you're probably gonna
get right around 75 80 miles right I
guess no trouble merging right huh
absolutely not if I'm a car nut I know
cars inside and out I can probably build
one of these puppies in my garage with
three lug nuts to give me half an hour
so feel free to use the real lingo what
kind of engine are we talking about this
is actually a Berlin block it's a 540
cubic inch by 40 cubic yeah that's a
sweet yeah we got fuel injection in this
problem we do that fuel injection yeah
and tell me a little bit about
crankshaft what are we talking about
distribution we're talking about full
down a staggered staggered you know the
probe is staggered if you don't mind me
laying in just get a vehicle that has a
little bit less torque in the mid runs
what do you think I know I agree with
you yeah I agree with you yeah we'd make
up court on top in I make up front of on
top do you ever forget when you're not
in a monster truck let's say you've been
driving around on the monster truck
crushing stuff crushing stuff okay then
you leave and you get in your Prius to
go home and and you forget for a second
and you try and crush a mobile home only
you're killed instead is that happen yet
what are the athletic requirements of
learning to drive one of these babies
what do I need to do you think I'm in
fit to do it I think you're looking good
all right would you like to feel free
put your hands on me all around all
around this part here now go down here
okay get in here what do you think I'm
limber I laid you move they can move
what is the is there do you need
athletic ability to do this well this
sounds dangerous and foolhardy let's do
it
[Applause]
we are now in our fireproof suits first
thing I notice is that you guys have
lots of cool colors and I look like I
work in a high-end Japanese spa I think
I'm ready to get in the truck should we
talk safety you know this should all be
reassuring but it is not
[Music]
[Music]
there's a weird smell in here and I just
realized it's because I myself is now
going to teach me how to drive the grave
digger
all by myself and then I'm going to
drive this monster truck all by myself
this is what we call in the industry a
bad idea you had your foot pedal for gas
that's your brake over here this
controls just the front steering we've
missed them switch fuel you want to have
the motor rotating actually before you
throw the switch oh you guys can't tell
me that again because while you were
explaining that to me I was thinking
about an episode of Breaking Bad which
I'm third button we can shut you down
remotely if we feel you're out of
controllers are doing something we don't
like so if you guys don't like what I'm
doing if you think I'm out of control
you can push a button and shut me down
yes that happened to me at NBC
[Applause]
I want to thank you you've given me at
least a minute and 40 seconds of
training I think I'm ready to drive this
five ton vehicle over some giant
obstacles okay here we go power
how'd I do
you've been great I had a blast now
we're gonna move right to a crazy stunt
that I'm going to do I'm gonna go up
this ramp and smash into that RV right
there we put four interns from our show
in the RV and we've tied them up we've
given them a box cutter and we're just
gonna it's up to them to get out you
can't get out that way that second I'm
just concentrating on holding the wheel
constant dependent steady throw let's
just start rolling the throttle a little
more and more as you go up the ramp and
just keep a steady throttle as you come
okay I think you're going through
everything all right all right thank you
ready
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
incredible
[Music]
[Applause]
look at that got a 10 a 10 and a one
who's the dick giving me the woman
[Applause]